Hello, I'm Joshua Rosenberg on a legal commentator,
and I've been invited by intelligence squared to present this podcast.
Joining me is Chris Dore,
QC it barrister specializing in criminal law and author of a new book called
justice on trial radical solutions for a system at
breaking point. Chris,
we've seen quite a few memoirs by criminal lawyers over the years,
and we've even seen one or two books by lawyers who think that the criminal
justice system is broken. What's what's special about your book?
I think it's the fact that I'm trying to draw together all of the strands in one
place. Um, I, I, it's not a memoir. Uh, although there are case studies,
as you know, and, and examples of the kind of cases I've done over a 25,
26 year career as a criminal defense lawyer. But,
but what I'm trying to do in the book is really try and hit the main headlines
of what's wrong with the system.
And many books have done that too in different ways in the past, as you say,
but then brought it all together in a kind of overarching kind of
polemic. If you like, as to, as to what we can do about it,
some real practical solutions as to how we can stop wasting money and stop
wasting lives in criminal justice, which suddenly I think we just do too much.
What about that?
Because you subtitled your book radical solutions for a system at breaking
point,
and perhaps the most radical visa is summed up in the title of chapter two,
why we should close all prisons, all prisons.
Yes. All prisons as we know them now. So my, my, um,
very strong belief is that the infrastructure of prisons, which largely is a,
is a hangover from the Victorian era. In fact, we still have many prisons, um,
which are operating, which were built in the Victorian era,
such as Strangeways in Manchester and many of the other large city prisons. Uh,
my view is that it's the infrastructure and the architecture of those
institutions, which actually in many ways, perpetuates criminality, which,
which creates an atmosphere within the institutions,
which really just says to people you're a criminal and we're going to treat you
like one and unsurprisingly, when you treat someone like a criminal,
they come out even more of a criminal than the one we went in.
Picture. But, but I mean, you know, all prisons have walls.
All prisons have bars, some prisons are modern, some prisons,
reasonably attractive. They're quite spacious those, uh, out in, out in, uh,
out of the city centers. Um,
are you saying that those are unsatisfactory as well?
Well, it's very interesting. No, they're all on satisfactory.
It's very interesting that you should say that they all have bars and they all
have walls in Britain. That's largely the case,
although not completely some of the low security prisons don't have walls for
example, and don't have bars. Um, but in other countries,
and I talk extensively about a number of other countries from a sort of extreme
deep South kind of, uh, a dystopian nightmare of the prisons of,
of the U S to the much more pragmatic, uh, uh,
progressive prisons of the Scandinavian countries. And in those countries,
prisons don't look like prisons. As we know them,
they look like residential communities. Now, some of them, but for the,
for those who are the most dangerous prisoners have security measures and
security fencing to prevent people escaping.
But once you get into the secure environment,
they try to make the environment look as much like normality as much as like the
outside world as possible.
And that's where I'm coming from because the focus of our prison system has
always been the client of the prison Gates and locking people up behind these
big walls and cell doors and bar AHS.
And actually the focus shouldn't be on the shocking and scaring people.
The moment they go into prison, it should be,
how do we prepare that person to actually fairly seamlessly move from prison
into normal life, where they can have a job. They can look after their family.
Um, and at the moment we're failing completely on that school because people are
just living in this state of alienation in this entirely, um,
kind of different universe of being prison. And when they come out,
they're blinking in the sunlight. They have no idea what to do.
And unsurprisingly, most of them commit more crime.
Way. Of course,
that we do prepare prisoners to be released is by putting them in open prisons.
And as you say,
there are some prisons where prisoners go out to work during the day and apart
from one or two punishment cells that they may have, uh, anybody who, uh,
disobeys the rules before they're chucked out of these open prisons and returned
to close conditions, they are, um, they don't have bars on the, on the,
on the doors and, you know, you can walk in and out of them all,
obviously you have to return and obey the rules,
but you are acknowledging though that some prisoners will still have to be
behind bars, even if the architecture is better than we have at the moment.
Yeah. So for me,
the important statistic and I deal with it extensively in the book is that 69%
of those who are in prison today every day in the UK on non-violent
offenders.
So they don't present a risk to the public of hurting people with committing
serious assault or murder or rape.
They are people who have committed crimes often financially driven and often
drug-related. And that's as you know,
a large chunk of the book revolves around drug policy. So yes,
there is a small minority of the prison population,
probably 10 to 15% who represented ongoing and immediate risk of harm to the
public. And they need to be kept in secure conditions,
but nearly every one of those will be released bar about
60 or 70, who are serving what we call full life terrorists, but,
but whole life terrorists rather. Um,
so 99.9% of all prisoners, no matter how violent the crime,
no matter if they've committed murder or several murders,
the great majority will be released one day.
And so even those most dangerous ones, they need to be kept secure,
but you've still once you've got them in a secure environment,
which can be done through electronic means. And of course,
through fencing and the light that doesn't have to be a great big brick wall to
keep people in. But once they're inside the environment,
I still believe no matter how serious their crime that they should be treated or
that the conditions should be as normal as possible.
They should have normal living arrangements as much as possible, for example,
to cook their own food in all the kitchens,
rather than so shuffling into a Victoria mess hall, queuing up for food,
to be slopped onto a plate, the sort of conventional image of prisons.
That's just putting people in an environment which takes them away from the
mainstream and makes it harder and harder for them to reintegrate when they
finally get out.
But what you say is that we should leave those convicted of most crimes in their
own homes. You would prefer not to send many prisoners,
people who go to prison at the moment to prisoner tool.
You would prefer them to be monitored by electronic tags and so on.
But as you know, better than most people, many criminals don't have homes.
And if you didn't lock them up while they were awaiting trial,
they'd never turn up in court and they'd never be convicted.
Well, I,
I don't think we should be using the criminal justice system as much as we are
anyway, particularly for non-violent crimes. So, uh,
and you're absolutely right that many of those who are in the prisoners state
and the prison system are in there because they're homeless because they are
addicted to drugs or because they have mental health problems rather than
because they are inherently dangerous.
People who want to go out and commit crime for its own sake.
And so you're absolutely right to address the issue that many of those who enter
the system, they need care. What they don't need is to be punished,
to be locked up in Victorian conditions. Uh, and of course, when you do that,
and I tell the story in the book of, uh, of, uh,
clients and former clients about who,
who for the purposes of the book is called Michael. Um,
and he'd been in prison for 30 out of his 52 or so years of life.
And he told me very clearly. And, and I tell the, tell you the book. He said, I,
I don't, I don't like it on the outside.
I only know prison is the only way of life I have. And so when you,
when you spending millions to keep people locked up in institutions,
only for them to just keep coming back through the revolving door,
you've got to ask yourself why what's the point of that. Um,
but to answer your direct question. So, so of course anyone who's homeless,
shouldn't be homeless. So whether a criminal or not, and if we,
as a society accepting that people can be homeless and we just don't care and
therefore we'll put them in prison instead of, instead of a home,
then we're clearly getting something seriously wrong because as you know,
it cost 50,000 or so on average a year to keep someone in prison.
It costs a lot less than that to house someone in the community,
outside of prison and provide them safe, uh,
hygienic conditions and the ability to access health care and, you know,
decent living conditions.
So if someone's committed a non-violent crime and they're homeless,
then they should be given accommodation, but they shouldn't be sent to prison.
Last question from me on prisons, um,
it's almost 250 years since John Howard,
the great prison reformer, uh,
gave evidence to MPS on conditions in prisons. And of course,
many people have followed him over the centuries. What makes you think that, uh,
with your book,
you're going to be any more successful in engendering a reform of the prison
system?
Well, it's a, it's a good question. And I, uh,
my concern is actually that no matter how rational the suggestions and I believe
that they are really quite sensible and pragmatic,
they're not even complicated suggestions, but particularly around drug reform,
particularly around, uh, the,
just the S the complete failure of prisons to actually produce the
outcome that people want, which is fewer criminals and less crime.
That's the point of the criminal justice system,
and yet the criminal justice system and the prisons in particular achieve the
diametric opposite of that. So,
all I can hope is that by making an argument and I'm trying to make it
passionately, but also calmly and clearly basing it on evidence.
And I've traveled as you know, for the book all over the world,
I've been into prisons in different countries. I've looked at court systems,
I've interviewed judges from,
from different jurisdictions and prosecutors or defense lawyers and the
cumulative evidence that I am absolutely no doubt about is that the way we're
doing it now is failing.
And that there is a much more sensible way of trying to address crime,
which will actually save lives and reduce the amount of victims of crime.
And I guess, Joshua, the answer is,
am I cynical about whether there's likely to be uptake? Yes, I am.
Am I skeptical as to whether the politicians will buy into this? Yes,
I am sadly, but that, you know, I've had 25, 26 years of doing this job.
And I think a lot of what I do,
and a lot of what those of us in the system do is,
is really a waste of time because it achieves nothing except making things
worse.
So I think it's almost juicy bound to kind of say the emperor's got no clothes.
W w w we,
we pay lip service to justice and punishment and rehabilitation,
but actually the whole system is broken.
And if my ideas can get people talking,
and if we can even get a few steps on the road to a much more sensible,
a much more fair and rational system, then, then job done. Um,
cause at the moment there's very little debate actually around these things.
All right, well, let's move on to chapter three,
which is called why we should legalize drugs, all drugs.
Drugs. Uh, absolutely. Uh,
and of course the arguments I make is not as some would no doubt, um,
characterize it that there's a free for all, of course,
there isn't any more than there's a free for all for alcohol or cigarettes. Uh,
you would have quality controls. You would have licensing,
you would have processes and age restrictions and all of the things that go with
any licensed in toxicant, uh, wherever that, that might be sold in the world.
Um, but absolutely because the minute you start to prohibit a substance,
you create a black market for that substance. And once you have a black market,
that's where chaos reigns, that's where deaths happen.
And that's where overdoses happen.
That's where violent gang violence and turf Wars happened in a prohibited
market. So you can't, you can't, um, uh,
as you were carve some drugs out of legalization,
any more than you can cough most alcoholic drinks out of the system. I mean,
there are very, very, for an alcoholic drinks available to buy at 60, 70%,
80% proof,
but you restrict the sale of it and you restrict the licensing conditions around
those products. Um,
but if you restrict them too much and you make them accessible to people who
want them, then they,
then they will go to a dealer and there will be a black market. So,
absolutely I, I, I understand the argument. Some people say, well,
let's legalize cannabis. Actually cannabis is quite a dangerous drug, uh,
objectively, it's not as dangerous as alcohol or tobacco,
but it's still a dangerous drug. Um, so I don't,
I don't buy into the whole classification.
One's better than another basically human beings take drugs.
And this is the point I'm making the book. As you know,
I w P human beings have taken,
there is evidence that human beings were ingesting psychotropic plants as long
as 200 million years ago.
And certainly for tens of millions and certainly throughout human civilization
for, for the last 10,000 years, you'll never going to stop it.
And the point I make is if you can't stop something,
you need to regulate license and control the supply of it so that you create
safer conditions for those who choose to use.
And now you say regulate and control the supply, but if you make drugs legal,
then surely more people will take them. Is that right or not?
That's not the evidence of any system where there's been a degree of
liberalization or degree of decriminalization,
but what we haven't seen actually,
other than in a few States in the U S and a few other countries in relation to
cannabis,
but we haven't seen is a comprehensive regulatory and
licensing system of the kind that is applied to alcohol,
so that you have to have a license to sell it.
You have to have a license to produce it. You have to,
you can only produce a certain standards. Um, I mean, one of the,
I think the main point of the book, when you go buy a children's toy,
it's subject to 57 different regulations from the EU,
from international regulation to every degree of safety standard,
and yet a 15 year old child.
As I tell the tragic story of Martha from back in the book,
a 15 year old child can go out on the streets and buy ecstasy.
That's 91% pure that could kill a horse,
and there's no regulation, and there's no licensing of that product.
There's no regulation, except that is illegal. But, but let, let, let, let,
let me talk about the age, because you say that she was a 15 year old girl,
she sadly died. Um, you say you would set an age limit for, uh,
purchasing drugs legally. W where would you put that age limit?
Well, the age, the age may vary depending on the drug. Um, uh, but I, I,
I think that 16 or 18 was a logical is a logical place to start, uh,
depending on the nature of the drug. Um, but, but you, you make a valid point,
which is yes, of course, under any system,
you wouldn't make drugs freely available to ten-year-olds, for example.
Hey, you, you say, you say 16, and this girl who tragically died was 15.
So she wanted to continue to take drugs as she did. Um,
then she would have to take drugs illegally.
Yes, she would. But the, but the, the product to which she would have access,
just like when a 17 year old drinks, alcohol,
the 17 year old who drinks alcohol,
doesn't go and take a hundred percent volume moonshine. They get alcohol,
that's been bought by someone else,
legally in a supermarket or an offline license.
And they know that it's what the product is.
That doesn't mean it can't make the meal, but what they,
what they can't do as a 15 or 16 year old is go buy alcohol. That will,
if they take one drink of it will kill it. That's the difference.
Yeah.
But the 15 year old might still be targeted by a pusher who would give
her, uh, dangerous drugs. And under your scheme,
she would have to get an older person to buy her, the drug parent,
perhaps older sibling, or lie about her age and, and, and commit an offense.
So she would just, uh,
still be targeted by drug pushers or by people who would sell her drugs more
cheaply than she could buy them lawfully. Surely.
Well, no, if you think about it. So Martha's mother, uh,
Emory who I interviewed for the book and I, I,
I was a really kind of powerful source of, of both information,
but also kind of common sense of pragmatism Martha's mother is in no doubt.
And I'm in no doubt that no, no, in a,
in a market where you could go and buy ecstasy tablets,
or FDMA the strength that is the strength that users want to take.
So it gets them high, but they come down the next day and they're okay.
A couple of days later that nobody wants to take 91% pure MTMA,
which will kill you, which will instantly kill you. Nobody wants to take that.
And no dealer wants to sell that to somebody, but she was,
she didn't buy it at 91% pure because the dealer intended to sell her 91% pure.
The dealer didn't know, that's the thing you were in, in the,
in an uncontrolled unregulated market,
drugs are mixed up in cement mixers or people's kitchens.
So someone's got 0% and someone else has got 91%.
If you have a market where the, where the,
the dosage is controlled and written on the packet,
there is absolutely no incentive for people to buy drugs.
That'd be produced in another way, any more than the race,
an incentive for people to go out and buy alcohol that's been produced
illegally, or, or still somewhere there's a tiny,
tiny percentage of alcoholism is made in that way, but it's,
it's insignificant 99% of alcohol is either sold,
is a licensed illegal product. It may have been bought by someone under age,
but at least the product is as safe as it can be.
And you know what you're taking and the,
and the point I'm making the book is if Martha had been 15 and she'd pass
herself off as 18 as he went into a pub,
what she couldn't do is buy a drink that she sit and then dropped dead on the
floor. And she was able to do that in this market.
Let's talk about heroin. Uh,
heroin would be available to heroin users. Uh,
would these people be able to hold down responsible jobs while
taking heroin so that they could pay for their drugs or would heroin use?
It's a very good question. So we're very good question.
So one of the places I've visited in the course of my research was the heroin
assisted treatment program in Geneva and Switzerland is led the way for many,
many years,
Switzerland had a horrific problem with heroin in the eighties and the fruits of
the early nineties, where they had people shooting up in parks.
They had skyrocketing levels of HIV infection.
They had massive rates of overdose and heroin deaths.
So they decided to do something about it.
And what they did was introduced a number of different measures,
but the most radical and the most important one was a heroin assisted treatment
program where heroin users were, are able. And I saw them, I visited the center.
I spoke to the head of the unit psychiatrist, wonderful psychiatrist, uh,
out there. And they visit the center twice a day.
They come in the morning and they come in the evening. And many, many of them,
if not the majority do exactly what you say,
which is they come for their heroin in the morning, they go to work or college,
they come back, they have more heroin in the evening,
and then they carry on with their lives. And then they get that heroin.
I was just going to say, is the heroin provided free for them?
Or these are the sentences?
Well, not exactly. They have a very interesting approach in Switzerland.
So this is the Swiss Supreme court decided that heroin addiction and the other
addictions, uh, uh,
our disability in law and therefore under Swiss law,
a disability is something for which you're entitled to very substantial health
and financial support.
If it's a physical disability or a mental health disability, or an addiction,
they're treated the same way.
So what happens is that heroin addicts I'll give them the same medical and
social security payments as everybody else. Who's disabled,
who may not be able to walk or may need assistance with their life in another
way. And it's that benefit as it were as a disabled, as the disability,
as an illness, which is used to fund the heroin assisted treatment program,
which provides the heroin, but of course, heroin, pharmaceutical, heroin,
which is pure, and which has a known dosage,
and which cannot possibly have any adulterants that a or B of such a sprint that
it would kill you is actually relatively cheap.
It's not an expensive product to produce for a government under license.
It's only expensive when it's sold on the street by dealers who have to have a
whole criminal supply chain going right back to Afghanistan,
or all the original poppy fields where the, where the,
where the heroin or the opium poppies are growing.
It's because of all the illegality and the need to constantly sell and resell
and cut and uncut. And so that's why street heroin is so expensive.
And that's why street heroin users have to commit so much crime,
but actually their dosage costs just a few,
few quid a day when it's produced and supplied lawfully by the state.
Cause it's not an expensive drug. So, so what happens in Switzerland?
What's the outcome. The outcome is straightforward.
The vast majority of those patients who go to that unit live a law abiding life
and don't commit crime because they don't need to because they don't have to go
out and commit crime to get the heroin. And the vast majority is 80% in the end,
come off heroin because,
because actually heroin use is often symptomatic of some other issue in life.
It's often symptomatic that someone's in distress or has mental health problems,
or is in pain.
And once they're in the medical system and they obtain their hair, heroin,
medically, all of those other problems start to be solved as well.
And so you see heroin usage over time reduces there is the level of crime
reduces or the overall cost of that system per user is,
is a tiny fraction of the overall cost that we spend in this country on and in
the U S on heroin users, which of course is mainly criminal justice,
health interventions. The cost of that, there were,
there were virtually no heroin overdoses in Switzerland because heroin users
have access to medical care.
They have access to the drugs that are needed if they do take a little bit too
much immediately without any judgment upon them. Whereas in Britain,
including some of our major cities like Glasgow,
the rate of overdose is absolutely catastrophic and in the States it's even
higher. So, so we're killing people by prohibition,
in a country that has legalized and licensed heroin treatment.
The heroin user is much safer. And so is the general public. Okay.
I've got some broader questions to ask you in a moment,
we're going to take a break. Now I'm Joshua Rosenberg. My guest is Chris Dore,
and we'll be back after this short break,
crystal,
your roadmap would be fine if we didn't have to start from where we
are. Now, people turn to crime.
People turn to drugs because of the way they were brought up.
If you want to move people away from a life of crime,
you have to start almost at birth. Certainly when they're youngsters,
certainly you have to bring them up in a way that avoids them being drawn into
crime, being drawn into illegal drugs.
You can't really adapt the situation now, uh,
without changing the whole thing,
it's going to take you a decade or more of people, uh,
in this situation before you can actually start to see reforms,
because it's only the people who you might start to bring up from an early age
now who are going to, uh,
go through with the reform that you're talking about.
Well,
obviously to completely change and radically changed the entire approach to
criminal justice. Isn't an overnight thing.
And I fully accept that it would take a decade or more to start to see the full
benefits of what I'm proposing apart from anything.
If you're going to knock down a prison that contains a thousand or 1500 people,
uh, or you've then got to find somewhere else for them initially,
or you've got to find some other kinds of, uh,
roots out of the justice system for them. So of course,
rebuilding restructuring the entire prison estate is a massive job,
and it would take a decade or more to do that,
but there are some easy wins and drug legalization,
and licensing is one of the easy wins because drug drug use and drug
prohibition is behind probably by most estimates,
60 to 70% of the entire criminal justice system.
So 60 to 70% of violence, 60, 70% of property crime.
And of course there's drug crime itself,
which many thousands of people are in prison just for,
just for the drug crimes themselves. So just by over a,
say one to two year period, probably two years,
by the time you could do it in a sensible way to move back actually to the
system we used to have in England before 1971,
we used to have what was called the English system,
which was that heroin was available from certain doctors on prescription.
There were a small number of heroin users that were very few problem users. Um,
and then we criminalized it in 1971. And within a decade,
there were 300,000 plus people who were addicted to heroin.
And that was the direct effect as I make the point in the book. But,
but if you reverse that course, you would begin to see. So,
so you would stop. Um, for example,
you would shut down much of the organized crime network almost overnight.
I mean, big time drug dealers,
some of whom I've represented some of the largest importers of drugs, uh,
into this country, I'd be my clients.
The one thing they all agree on is that prohibition is great for them. It's the,
it's the only thing that keeps them in business and the,
and their absolute worst nightmare is legalization because they suddenly have no
source of income anymore. So when you think about it that way round, you know,
why is it that big drug dealers are happy with the status quo? Um,
it does strike you somewhat, you know, uh, of, uh, of, uh,
at least an alarm bell that should be ringing. Um, but,
but legalization and licensing of drugs would have a dramatic effect within a,
within a five-year timeframe.
It would dramatically reduce the volume of people going through the criminal
justice system.
It will dramatically reduce the amount of crime and violence on the streets.
And you would see that change very quickly. Some of the other things, I mean,
you could also move very quickly on, on my, my other proposal,
which is to raise the age of criminal responsibility from 10 as it is at the
moment,
I'm would predict a situation with 10 year old children are sitting in court,
charged with crimes. I mean, it's just ludicrous and, and,
and offensive to anyone who, who knows anything about children,
let alone anything else. Um, but, but if you did that,
if you raise the age of criminal responsibility,
as they have done in Luxembourg and most other countries have a much higher age
of criminal responsibility than us, then again,
you would divert what these children who go into the revolving door of criminal
justice from the age of 10, 11, 12, they will be diverted.
You'd have to have resources for them,
but it will be a hell of a lot cheaper to provide resources and youth services
than it is to put them in the criminal justice system and leave them there for
life. I mean,
it costs millions to have a child go through criminal justice for life.
Yeah.
I'll ask you about that because I attended the trial of John Venables and Robert
Thompson,
the two ten-year-olds who murdered two year old James Bolger in 1993,
uh, as you know, they were tried in an adult court, but they avoid precedent.
Uh, yes. Uh,
and it was extraordinary seeing them because there they were on raised chairs,
but their heads are only just above the level of the dock.
This was Preston crown court, a very traditional court, you know, well,
they avoided the adult prison system, at least Thompson did. Now, as you say,
10 is the age of criminal responsibility in England Wales, Northern Ireland,
Scotland, I think is in the process of raising it from eight to 12.
What do you think insurance?
It should be 18 in my view, um, it should be 18 as it is in Luxembourg,
because how can you justify telling a,
a child you're not young enough,
you're not old enough to make a decision as to who you want to be your MP.
You're not old enough to decide whether you have a drink of alcohol or not.
You're not old enough to drive a car,
but you're old enough for us to hold you responsible completely for all of your,
as if you are an adult.
And we will treat you for criminal purposes as if you're an adult,
but for no other purpose, no other purpose.
You've represented 17 year old, 16 year olds. Some of them,
I think most people would say are pretty mature.
They may well be living on their own. Uh, they may have one parent at home,
but they may not be with their parents at all. Uh,
surely those people are old enough. Those, uh, senior teenagers,
if you like are old enough to know what's right and wrong, and to be,
uh, to be susceptible to the criminal justice system.
I don't agree. I don't agree at all. I don't, you aren't,
you have to make a choice as to what the age of maturity and adulthood is.
And all of the evidence is clear. I mean,
I spent time last year filming a BBC series, and I spent, uh,
some time in a young offender institution in Scotland.
I interviewed the governor that, who I talked about the interview in the book,
and she was crystal clear that the maturation process of a young man,
but also young women in slightly different way. Um,
it really doesn't fully complete until the early to mid twenties.
So the idea that you treat a 15 or 16 or however mature,
they are on the surface in the same way as you would a 30 or 40 year old,
a mature adult, again, it's just, it defies the evidence.
The evidence is that the maturation process does not really fully complete.
That doesn't mean that you can't, you don't do anything. I mean,
even in a country like Luxembourg, where as I say, you can't be,
you can't be deemed to have committed a crime at the age of 50,
but there are secure schools and they are called schools.
They're places of education where you restrict the Liberty of children who are
very dangerous and violent, and can't be safe to be on the streets.
But it's all about the mindset. It's about once you,
once you tell a child that they're a young offender,
they then become an offender and that's what they perceive themselves as.
And that's how they behave. But you treat them as.
I was just going to say, surely if you lock them up and as you say,
they would have to be in secure conditions, even if they're being taught.
And so on, surely if you lock them up,
they see themselves as apart from everybody else.
And they see themselves as being punished simply because they can't go out and
enjoy themselves like other teenagers.
But, but it would be in my kind of ideal scenario. There'd be very, very few.
I mean, I mean, if you think about the point I made earlier about the,
about the adult prison system,
there's only a small percentage of that system who are entrenched violent
individuals who present an immediate risk to the public.
There's an even tinier percentage of young offenders in that category.
And so rather than, you know, having, having a philosophy that you, that you,
it doesn't, you don't distinguish well. I mean,
when you go to a young Zen young offenders institution,
it's just a prison that were prison uniforms. They bang with the cell doors.
It's exactly the same as a prison.
And that's what that's deeply offensive to me. So would,
if you put them in a secure school that had a secure fence,
there would have been a handful for the entire country who will be so dangerous
as to need those conditions.
The great majority of children would simply go to a much better
form of education environment, which would allow,
which would be specialized around. Many of them are deeply damaged. I mean,
there's a very statistic.
I mentioned the book that the care leavers are 15 times more likely to
go to prison or young offense institutions than other children. And you, you,
you say to yourself, well, how are we not responsible or I do anyway,
how are we not responsible for that? Well, you know, we can't,
you can't blame these. They're not 15 times more inherently dangerous at birth.
We've done something with them in the care system and their lives as children
have been so damaged that they end up having to go through the system,
or we actually then it trench it or make it worse by criminalizing them and
brutalizing them in the, in the, uh, in the custodial environment.
But care leavers are precisely the people who are likely to be homeless.
They don't have secure home lives. They couldn't live at home and go to school.
So you'd have to put them in some sort of accommodation,
whether you have a high wall around it or not,
because they're the people who need structure,
who needs support and who may well need, uh,
telling that they must be there and they can't go off.
And as they would at the moment, if you consider them to be crimes,
commit more crimes.
Uh, I just, I just find the whole language.
And I know that you're sort of paraphrasing an argument.
I'm not suggesting that you're expressing your own view,
but I find the whole narrative around, you know, the need to, to, to,
to lock people off and the mindset of
treating them as if they are inherently evil. And of course, as you know,
one of the big themes of the book is that people are not evil.
They come out of the womb with some different kind of otherness,
as it were some,
some terrible kind of a genetic predisposition to criminality. I mean, that's,
that's well known evidentially. Um, and,
and you just have to stop saying a child is, is, is a criminal.
And that's why th that that's just my view. And the minute you stop doing that,
you will improve the outcomes. And, and that's okay.
How do you think this is going to go down with the wider public,
who regard these people as criminals,
if they've stolen things or attack people or assaulted people,
or even more serious offenses, which you see increasingly in cases of knife,
crime are committed by youngsters and the public think that governments should
protect them from the people they regard as criminals.
And if you're going to have any success in this,
you've got to persuade the politicians that there is some way
in which they can persuade their electors,
that closing prisons, legalizing drugs,
raising the age of criminal responsibility is actually going to
work. It's the voters who don't have any confidence in this.
And it's not surprising that politicians, if they want to succeed,
uh, are giving people what the people seem to want. Well,
you're absolutely.
Right. And that's where we are, where we are.
That's why our system is so catastrophic, really damaging and failed so much.
Um, and the way the U S system, which is, you know,
many times greater in terms of numbers, 2.3 million, I call the,
the U S prison population in the book, the city of incarceration.
It would be the fifth largest city in America. If, uh,
if it were actually a city. Um, aye, aye, aye,
aye. Illustrate your point. Precisely in the book.
When I talk about that interview that I did with a judge who refused to be who
understand that he was off the record and elected criminal judge in, in,
in Alabama. And I said to him, you know, you've got the,
you've got death penalty. You've got you lock away 18 year olds for life,
without parole, for drugs, offenses, not even for violent crimes. Uh,
you've got this vast prison population, um,
and whole chunks of your communities in inner cities, which are,
have virtually no young black men left because you've locked nearly all of them
up. And yet your crime rates, the murders, the robberies,
and the shootings and stabbings are a hugely massive levels. And he said,
you know, I know you're right. It doesn't work.
If everything we're doing is completely wrong. I said, well,
why the hell are you doing it doesn't make any sense. And he said,
because if I were to argue for any of the things that you believe in,
either I believe in,
then I'd never win election and I'd be out of office in five minutes flat. So,
so you're right.
There's a disconnect between the reality evidence of what reduces crime,
which are the sorts of things I advocate and what people instinctively and
emotionally want. And I go into the whole history of that in the book, you know,
because I go back to, you know, justice in,
in the Mayan civilizations Roman times,
and always there is this instinctive eye for an eye mentality.
And that sadly people buy that because it's a very saleable message.
It's much easier to sell crack downs and toughness than it is. Hey,
hold on a minute.
Let's listen to a nuanced argument about evidence people switch off.
And that's why I tried to make the argument simple. You talked about my, my,
my chapter headings, you know, I'm trying to, you know, give,
give the other side a run for its money.
Uh, let me, uh,
bring the situation up to date with the criminal justice system as it is now,
we've seen a lot of complaints in,
in recent weeks by people who say they've been stopped by the
police purely because of the color of their skin.
Do you think that something's gone particularly wrong in terms of racial
profiling, the way the police operate.
Lately? It's been wrong for generations. I mean,
it's been wrong for decade after decade it's,
but it's obviously at its most extreme wrong in the
United States. And, and there's no surprise to me that hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of people who have been on the streets,
protesting black lives matter in the States, I have a, a client and,
and there's been an, uh, he he's, he was interviewed,
I can disclose it cause he was interviewed for channel four news. Recently,
a young black bank manager who had never been in trouble in his life
was in his mid to late thirties. Very successful,
reached quite a high position already in one of the major banks. Um,
he was stopped in his very nice car,
which he paid for out of his very handsome salary almost every month and
asked where's the money for the car come from.
And that experience of young black men,
whether they be professionals like him or whether they just be young men who are
driving around money and they're in business,
that experience of constantly being challenged about how you can justify just
walking down the street or while you've got nice clothes or where you've got a
nice car that is absolutely catastrophic for relations
between the police and the community.
And it leads to this tension and it leads to this sense of injustice and a
justified one, which, which many, uh, black and minority ethnic people feel,
uh, and it's just institutionalized. It was,
it was shown as institutionalized by the Stephen Lawrence inquiry and sad to say
it remains institutionalized, but not necessarily to an individual level,
but just the way in which police he works.
If you're a 17 or 18 year old white middle-class boy from a nice area and you
and your mates go out and take cocaine at the weekend,
the chances that you will be arrested or stopped or challenged,
but virtually zero,
if you're a young black man walking the streets of East London,
the chances you'll be challenged are infinitely higher and that's where it goes
wrong. So you end up where you don't have, like for like,
because one community is treated in a totally different way to another
community, even though the outside, they are,
their actions are exactly the same. So we have to do something about that.
It's really important.
Last question. Um,
let's imagine you were made home secretary tomorrow or justice secretary if you
prefer. Yep.
I'll be quite critical of Boris Johnson. You know,
it seems an improbable scenario, but we'll go with your thought experiment.
One of the problems because he remains prime minister and he is not going to
keep you in that cabinet post a very long, if you annoy him,
nor is he going to give you very much money, uh,
certainly not much more money than the present incumbents have. And, uh,
yet he says, well, you know,
solve the problems with all the constraints of the voters and the treasury.
What's the first thing you do.
You have to go down some route of drug reform,
drug law reform because it's cost it's, it's an immediate cost benefit.
It reduces. So you actually will spend much less money if you,
if you reform drug laws. And I don't think if I, in the, uh,
inconceivable scenario that I were called upon to service or as Johnson's home
secretary, I don't think, uh, it would be, uh,
attractive to him to follow the whole of my, um, agenda. In other words,
the liberalization and the regulation of all drugs,
but I would start with heroin assisted treatment.
I would start with the licensed and, uh,
NHS led heroin assisted treatment program.
They're starting it in Glasgow in a very small way.
So it's coming to some extent to the United Kingdom.
I appreciate that's a devolved system and not under Boris Johnson's c'mon,
but I would start by saying, let's at least do something about heroin.
Let's go back to the system we had before the 1971 act with heroin treatment
that would, that would have an enormous impact.
And it have a huge economic and treasury impact,
a beneficial impact from the very start. So I'd start to argue around that.
And then if I were there long enough, I might start to say, Hey,
this has worked. Let's look at how we might do it with other drugs. And, and,
and, and by the way, bars,
how about we just experiment with another form of prison environment and just
see whether if we,
if we have prisoners living in fairly normal conditions and cookie,
the right food, and maybe their families can come and stay there,
if that's considered safe,
and then they come out and they refund only 20% like Norway rather than 75% as,
as, as here. Well, hold on. That experiment was quite successful.
And then by the time I started my second term, Joshua, the same secretary,
or perhaps even be promoted by then, we might be able to, uh,
we might be able to, to, to, to crack on with the rest of my agenda.
Christo QC many. Thanks indeed,
for telling me about your new book justice on trial,
you can read more about Chris's book and the podcast description.
There it is on the screen for those of you who are watching, uh,
those of you who are listening can see it on the podcast description,
where you'll also find a link to my new book,
which is called enemies of the people aren't Joshua Rosenberg.
And this podcast was produced by intelligence squared.